[Applause]
the epitome of keep calm and carry on
William and Kate are in Bradford the
soap opera around Harry and Megan was
not going to stop them how is the summit
dodging that question in front of a
largely supportive crowd things are
change and still no happy no the old
traditions for the roads
the younger generation one of the main
reasons that the Queen wants this to be
sorted out so quickly is so that it
doesn't continue to overshadow important
engagements like this the problem is
Harry and Megan and our huge
international stars so we can only
expect that clash between different
engagements by the sixes and the rest
are all family to continue the noise
around Harry and Megan isn't dying down
we saw the first picture of Megan in
Canada visiting a Women's Center in
Vancouver
while husband Harry announced the next
Invictus games this year we are heading
to the home you get the sense this is a
couple looking forward to having more
control I think one of the big things
for them is about you know looking at
international charities looking at
Charities in America using their star
power to really create a force for good
that might have been quite restricted
when they were part of that sort of
famous Fab Four working together was the
rather appropriate theme of the day
William's thoughts on community spirit
may be a nod the divides in his own
family sometimes trying to get people to
understand that it's okay to have these
challenges we just need to deal with
them we need to be forward rather than
just he's stuck in paralysis and attend
the North they don't happen boxer Amy
can't joined William and Kate to focus
on encouraging closer race relations as
behind the scenes there are still those
who believe that Megan has been the
subject of racism from the British press
well I don't think England near the
waist is country I'm you know we've been
living here we we are well respected I
hope they saw all the issues I really
are I've been in a position like that
myself a long long time ago where you
know you are you do feel unwanted bomb
sure they'll they'll get to the bottom
of it and hopefully things get better
[Music]
this is a couple who have very
traditional roles ahead of them ready to
pick up the baton from older members of
the family as we still wait to see how
this is all going to play out for his
brother
Riano Mills Sky News in Bradford